- Want some of this?
Mm, Vienna sausage, so tasty.
By 2050, reports predict that
there will be more plastic
in the ocean than fish.
How does this plastic even get
in the ocean in the first place?
Well a lot of it is from
the trash in our streets
that go into our storm drains
and then washed out into our oceans.
So today, I'm gonna be trying
to pick up all the trash
in my neighborhood.
I live in beautiful Little
Armenia, Los Angeles.
Which is a relatively small
neighborhood in east Hollywood.
I have no idea how much
trash there will actually be,
but I'm gonna try to
pick up as much as I can.
Okay, already I see some trash.
This is in my apartment complex, too.
So there was street cleaning
on the side of this street today.
I know, plastic is so scary.
I think I might fill these
bags with just one block.
Which is crazy.
I don't think I'm gonna be able
to do the whole neighborhood.
I'm gonna try, we'll see how far I get.
This I can recycle.
Put it in my recycling one.
All these little pieces of plastic,
they take like 400 plus
years to break down.
All the plastic that has ever been created
still exists on our world.
So the idea of throwing something away,
there's really no away.
Anyone want some nacho cheese?
Hey, this street's a little cleaner.
I mean, if you look closely,
there's definitely still pieces of trash.
I'm just focusing on the big pieces
'cause there's so many little pieces.
I'm not bothering to pick
up the cigarette buds.
It's too much.
So much random (bleep).
It is really crazy on how many McDonald's
and Starbucks straws I'm seeing.
I don't know what this is.
This is trash.
I'm gonna put these clothes in
and maybe we can take 'em to the Goodwill.
Well we're definitely
getting across the point
that there's a lot of
trash in my neighborhood.
The whole furniture is trash,
but I can't get all of it.
Okay, so I got so much trash and clothes
that I asked Amuro to come
and help me load some of it in
so I can keep on picking
up trash, thank you.
This is how straws and other
plastics get into the ocean.
They go into these drains and
then they washed out to sea.
Premium vodka.
Can recycle this.
Some chicken bones, delicious.
This is definitely not a one person job.
But I just wanted to see
what it would be like
and see how much trash actually is there.
'Cause, like, I notice it but then,
I haven't actually spent
time trying to pick it up.
It's pretty clean over here.
It is crazy though,
just like the difference
in neighborhood, in how
one neighborhood in L.A.
has trash and the other ones don't.
Trash in the trees,
I'm a little surprised.
Okay, we're back on my street.
Just gonna do the other side.
Okay, so we made it back to my apartment.
This is actually a crazy amount of trash.
I definitely didn't pick up all the trash
in my neighborhood.
In fact, I probably only covered like 20%,
but for three hours,
I think this is a crazy amount of waste.
These three bags are all textile waste.
Which I'm gonna donate to Goodwill.
And this is recycling
which I'm gonna recycle.
And this is all just trash.
The most common items
that I saw on the street,
besides textile waste, were
flyers, cigarette packages,
and fast food packaging.
I'm gonna throw it away.
If you're bummed about
seeing trash in our streets
and wondering what you can do about it,
you can start by trying to
cut out single use plastics
like straws, to-go
cups, and water bottles.
Good luck.
I'm in love with this drabber now.
It's gonna be a lifelong relationship.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.